cherchons
cher pierre françois sheikh membre de la
famille veille monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les chefs de
gouvernements mesdames et messieurs en
vos grades et qualités votre nombre vos
qualités votre présence la présence de
tant et tant de nos concitoyens qui sont
là parmi nous sans le témoignage vivant
de l'importance de cet instant au moment
de rendre à simone veil l'hommage de la
nation après les témoignages si puissant
et poignant de ses deux fils suspendant
un instant le fil obligé des discours
officiels et contemplons cette vie car
elle ne cesse décidément de nous étonner
jamais nous ne pourrons mesurer les
souffrances si profonde
ces violentes de celle qui brise d'une
âme qu'il s'agisse de la noire
expérience des camps de la mort où
moururent sa mère bien aimée yvonne son
père andré son frère jean plus tard du
décès accidentel de sa soeur madeleine
compagne de déportation et de son neveu
luc de la mort trop précoce de son fils
claude nicolas enfin de la disparition
d'antoine si présent aujourd'hui dans
nos pensées dans notre coeur
antoine l'indispensable antoine toujours
bouillonnant d'idées et d'histoire sig
est au fond si solide mais jamais non
plus
de cette vie nous pourrons peser
exactement l'invincible ardeurs l'élan
profond père ce qui est juste et bien
et l'énergie inlassable à le faire
triompher
oui cette vie de femme offre à notre
regard des abymes dont elle aurait dû ne
pas revenir et des victoires éclatantes
qu'aucune autre qu'elle n'aurait su
remporter à ce mystère d'existence de
caractère à ce mystère qui défie la
raison commune et nous inspire tant de
respect de fascination nous donnons en
france un nom bien ancrée dans notre
génie national ce nom c'est la grandeur
cette grandeur et celle des combats
qu'elle livre à les uns après les autres
parfois les uns en même temps que les
autres car ce ne furent ni plus ni moins
que les combats du siècle son engagement
pour transférer en france sous statut de
réfugié politique
ces femmes qui subissait dans les geôles
françaises en algérie le viol la fin les
coûts fut d'une lucidité implacable
généreuse qui aujourd'hui encore nous
stupéfier sa bataille pour que cessent
les conditions sordides et meurtrières
dans lesquelles se déroulaient les
avortements
mais aussi contre l'hypocrisie sociale
qu'il ait favorisé fait partie
pleinement de l'histoire de notre
modernité son combat pour l'europe
ne doutez pas de son élection comme
député au parlement européen puis comme
première présidente de celui ci il
remontait plus loin dans l'intimité même
de son existence
eelv était de 1945 les plaies de la
déportation n'était pas refermé
mais cela ne l'empêcha pas de vouloir
renouer avec l'allemagne un de ses
proches m'a fait cette confidence jamais
il n'entend dit simone veil prononcer
sur l'allemagne et les allemands la
moindre parole amer ou blessantes
elle est mal europe elle l'a défendit
toujours dans les moments où le pays
pouvait douter ou d'autres la critique
et elle était là parce qu'elle savait
qu'au coeur de ce rêve européen
il y avait avant tout ce rêve de paix de
liberté pour lequel elle s'est tant
battue elle ne fit pourtant pas de
l'oubli encore moins du pardon aux
bourreaux la condition de cette
réconciliation bien au contraire
parce qu'elle tenait que la mémoire est
là pour que l'inconcevable ne se
reproduise pas et non pour amoindrir
l'horreur je vois ici dans cette cour
tente et ans
le compagnon de ces combats menés durant
tant d'années alors que trop nombreux
étaient ceux qui est prêt à ne rien dire
comme présidente de la fondation pour la
mémoire de la shoah
elle observe à cette ligne d'une
exigeance totale ne rien céder à l'oubli
redonner corps à toute trace redonner
des visages et des noms et réconciliée
d'autres combats ils sont si nombreux
nous reviennent à l'esprit comme celui
pour la ratification de la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme
à la tribune des nations unies celui de
la protection sociale
ces combats de ministres aux côtés de
valérie giscard d'estaing jacques chirac
françois mitterrand et edouard balladur
celui des droits de l'homme en
yougoslavie et partout toujours sa lutte
pour les femmes
son engagement contre le racisme contre
l'antisémitisme
les temps hélas lui fournir bien des
raisons de s'engager avec force
mais il ya plus encore ces combats
elle est menée à bien souvent avant que
la société et les moeurs ne les aient
fait leur avant que la majorité ne les
est adoptée elle eu raison
bien souvent avant l'opinion commune et
souvent contre elle
simone veil fut cette éclaireurs de la
république qui monte seul à l'assaut de
bastille réputée imprenable et qui
pourtant les prend pour ensuite nous les
offrir en partage à nous qui n'avions
pas cru que cela serait possible ou qui
par indifférence parfois avions permis
que le scandale prospère aujourd'hui la
république s'enorgueillit d'avoir livré
ses combats mais avons nous toujours été
juste avec cette juste le salaire de son
courage ce fut souvent la haine
venimeuse d1 les injures exécrable des
autres de cela elle fut blessé mais
jamais abattue elle tenait être car elle
savait la solitude des pionniers le sort
cruel qu'on réserve à ce qui bouscule
l'ordre établi et dérangent
l'assoupissement général la victoire
était à ce prix car la victoire la
victoire en vérité n'avait pas de prix
la liberté aussi était à ce prix et
simone veil -le avait résolument choisi
elle su se tenir aux marges dans cette
insoumission intraitable et vigilante
qui lorsqu'elle se met en action obtient
les plus belles conquêtes échange ceux
qui se croyaient établi pour toujours
mais d'où lui venait cette force cette
volonté toujours de se battre pour des
causes justes
quelle fut cette boussole intérieure qui
toujours lui indiquer le chemin vrai
comment se fait-il que jamais elle ne se
trompe pas de combat à cela chacun
apportera sa réponse selon ceux qui
luttent à connaître d'elle je crois pour
ma part que le secret s'en trouve dans
son expérience si précoce et si radicale
de l'arbitraire et du mal de cela elle
tire a presque aussitôt une morale de
vie inaltérable la souffrance ne donne
qu'un droit celui de défendre le droit
de l'autre
tel était son absolue n'est de sa
douleur intime ineffaçable aider
protéger l'autre en particulier les plus
faibles nous le savons est lui souvent
la dent dure avec les plus puissants
mais elle fut toujours tendre avec les
faibles elle ne défend dis pas les
femmes parce qu'elles étaient femme mais
parce qu'elle était humiliée par la
puissance des hommes combien il reste à
faire à cet égard comme à tant d'autres
comme nous en avons encore besoin de
cette capacité de colère et d'action qui
jusqu'au bout
l'ani mer car ne nous y trompons pas
les combats de simone veil ne sont pas
des victoires acquises pour toujours
ce qui les a fait naître ressurgit sans
cesse ici ou ailleurs
aujourd'hui malheureusement dans trop
d'endroits en europe est au coeur de nos
sociétés intolérance sectarisme est une
fanatique ou doctrinaire extremis nous
avançant sous le masque d'un populisme
débonnaire compromission de toutes
sortes avec ceux qui piétinent notre
humanité reste des braises ardentes
prête à rallumer les pires embrasement
la détermination inexorable de simone
veil à faire prévaloir en tout l'humain
est ici notre cap son humanité du reste
n'était pas réservée à la sphère
publique
elle irrigue et son intimité à l'égard
de son épouse de ses fils de ses petits
enfants et arrière petits enfants aux
lettres si nombreuses qu'elles
recevaient des correspondants lointain
exprimer leur détresse ou leur solitude
elle répondait avec attention parfois
dit on cela irrite et un peu antoine l
employé pour cela une langue française
de grande élégance que nourrissaient sa
vive passion pour la littérature
française ce goût inculte et dès
l'enfance par son père il lui était si
fier de voir sa fille accueillis à
l'académie française
lorsqu'une vie se consacre à la justice
et singulièrement à la justice pour les
plus faibles les plus exposés les plus
humiliés lorsque cette vie est nourri
par une bienveillance sans partage à
l'égard de cette humanité dont pourtant
elle a vu la phase la plus hideuse et
lorsque cette vie choisi de se
construire sous l'égide de la république
c'est la france qui ai grandi
vous avez madame prodigués à notre
vieille nation des dons qu'ils ont fait
meilleure et plus belle vous avez jeté
dans nos vies cette lumière qui était en
vous et que rien ni personne n'a jamais
pu voter les français l'ont su l'ont
compris votre grandeur fille la nôtre
aussi
ce n'est pas seulement l'hommage de la
nation quand ce jour en deuil et nous
vous présentons c'est la france et
l'europe tout entière qui est là
témoignant de vos combats et au moment
où vous nous quittez je vous prie madame
de recevoir l'immense remerciements du
peuple français à l'un de ses enfants en
paix mais dans l'exemple lui ne nous
quittera jamais c'est pourquoi j'ai
décidé
en accord avec sa famille que simone
veil reposerait avec son époux au
panthéon
[Applaudissements]
car on a beau
[Musique]
présenté à